the verdict is in Tory Lanez found
guilty on all three counts in his
assault trial
where he was accused of a firing
gunshots at Megan the stallion I'm a
victim like I'm the victim like I don't
I'm not defended myself against anything
like something happened to me less than
a month after court proceedings began
the Canadian rapper now awaits
sentencing he faces more than 22 years
in prison and possibly deportation you
shot me stop lying prosecutors alleged
that in 2020 Tori and Megan left a pool
party at Kylie Jenner's home when Tory
fired shots at Megan's feet after she
exited the car they'd been riding in
they reached out and said you know Megan
is ready to talk back in April Megan
spoke to Gail about the incident on CBS
mornings all I hear is this man
screaming is he said dance and he
started shooting and I'm just like oh my
God
like he shot a couple of times
in the car shooting from the car Megan
he is standing up over the window okay
shooting I'm like oh my God if I take
the wrong step I don't know if he can
shoot something that's like super
important I don't know if he could shoot
me and kill me Tori was charged with one
felony count of assault with a
semi-automatic weapon and another count
of carrying a loaded unregistered
firearm in a vehicle last week Megan got
emotional during her four hour testimony
at one point saying quote I wish he
would have just shot and killed me if I
knew I was going to have to go through
this torture how has your life changed
since you were shot
I feel like my anxiety is worse
I feel like
my relationship with people is
it's it's gotten very cold after Megan
came forward with allegations she soon
faced an onslaught of Critics on social
media
what do you say to people that still
don't believe that you were actually
shot
I don't think any of this is for them
like it's for me like I know this
happened to me
and
I'd rather it play out in court and the
facts come out and everything comes out
that me having to plead my case because
I think she was just fed up with the
narrative that's out there she wanted to
control her own story you know this is
what's so sad to me is that there's
videotape there's a medical report there
is a police report and there are still
people that are trolling Megan online
and I think she ignored it for as long
as she could I really do believe that
and then I think it just got to her and
so for better or where she said I want
to say something hopefully people will
believe her but it but now she can at
least say I stood in my truth and I told
and I told my story
[Music]